you're real good because you have two
wins already tonight yes ma'am we do
come on Brandy I know I know I'm beyond
excited I'm still shaking from trying to
remember all the names and I'm just like
it's a whirlwind this day is like
nothing else it's so exhilarating it can
be so stressful it can be so
disappointing but but not today no man
seven nominations two wins already
you're gonna be taking that stage
tonight
um when you think about taking the
Grammy stage because of course you know
all of us at home are watching but then
you're in a room full of I mean think
about who who's in that room and you can
name everybody what goes through your
head tonight
um you know my performances on the
Grammys in the past have always been
this kind of culmination of my childhood
dreams that came from staying up late to
watch Whitney and Celine and see if they
could like hit those notes so I think I
wanted to sort of grow up and sing the
power note at the Grammys you know but
this year is going to be a little bit
different I feel like I just want to
come out there and just cut loose and I
and just be punk rock and just lay it
all out for everybody this is the first
year you've been nominated in that punk
category yes yeah yeah we just won the
rock and roll
um the two rock and roll Grammys we were
up for tonight and it was life-affirming
from a born and raised in Seattle
it just it felt really good and so
tonight I think that performance is
going to go to another level for me yeah
did I just see when um I think it was
Porsha that posted it of Ellen's
birthday and you were singing at their
vow renewal yes I was just I was just an
attendee and Porsha was like apropos of
nothing well you burst into the verse
the first verse of the first time ever I
saw your face and I was like
absolutely that's what I do
in front of like these Mega celebrities
I just had to go at the top of my lungs
the first time and they were looking at
me like this Brandy need some attention
right now
but I it was absolutely incredible and a
beautiful thing to witness we love them
they are our sisters Ellen seems so
surprised like I can't even believe this
is happening what am I supposed to do
she was surprised she was like really
she didn't even know how to act now I
also saw Harry and Megan in the crowd
yeah did you get to meet them and talk
to them yeah we talked to them for a
long time like British accents talked
about the enneagrams really actually
I know that everybody they just really
felt like very normal decent good
humored people we just had a great chat
that's good to hear because we see all
the hubbubs so to see them in a really
intimate setting just hanging out with
everybody yeah yeah and I mean I'm not
going to pretend I haven't seen the hell
up I've seen the hobo but
um I haven't paid very close attention
to it you know yeah it's been a great
year for women in music besides yourself
you know who are you looking forward to
seeing hit that stage tonight or who are
you rooting for oh my gosh there's so
many things tonight that I just gotta
see I love lizzo I saw lizzo last night
sings from the bottom of her feet to the
very tip of her head yeah and when she
gets on stage I screen like that I
scream I feel like a Beatles fan yeah
and and it's like and then also um and
she's performing right now in the
pre-tail but Madison Cunningham is so
brilliant she's I mean the closest thing
Our Generation has is Joni Mitchell and
I'm so excited to see what she does this
year and in the future
foreign